- What's you're about
to watch in this room
is a strange mortal combat
between a man and himself.
- Good day residents of the internet
and welcome back to the show that today,
pits two foreboding
anthologies against each other.
One is primarily in black and white,
the other in glorious Technicolor
and I wanna live in neither
because it's "Twilight
Zone" versus "Black Mirror."
The OG show from the
genius mind of Rod Serling
is going up against stiff competition
with the modern look at ourselves
and what we could or already have become.
It's the ultimate deconstruction
of two dystopian delights
that stand the test of time,
a match up that could only
happen in "The Twilight Zone".
- [Rod] You've just crossed
over into ""The Twilight Zone"."
- Here's how we'll determine a winner.
Round one Tomato Meters
slash audience score.
Round two iconic moments.
Round three, cultural relevance,
and then we'll toss a wild
card round into the mix
that helps settle the score.
And since this is the internet
and it lives on forever,
if any of those pig doctors
from the eye of the beholder
episode are watching,
this is what beauty used to look like.
All humans aiming for this.
Ask any of your swine brethren.
This is what handsome is.
Got it?
It's settled.
Okay, now we can start.
- Two stars?
Two stars?
- Wasn't a meaningful encounter.
- [Rod] They picked the most
dangerous enemy they can find,
and it's themselves.
- Round one Tomato Meter
slash audience score.
Back when ""The Twilight Zone"" began,
rotten tomatoes were just old veggies
you'd bring to a comedy show.
Critical gauges have
certainly evolved since 1959,
but so has ""The Twilight Zone."
After its initial run through 1964,
the show took a long breather.
It was then revived as a movie in 1983
and then a new series run through
the later part of the 1980s.
It went dormant again,
then returned on UPN
for one season in 2002,
like Pennywise the clown.
It would then depart only
to return years later
in its current iteration on CBS
with Jordan Peele stepping into
the Rod Serling curator role.
- [Jordan] Today, however,
she will have no choice
but to revisit history again and again.
- Peele has certainly turned the Zone
back into a fresh property
after the ill-fated movie and UPN run,
both earned rotten scores
on the Tomato Meter,
but the show has yet to return
to peak form in the 1960s.
The original Rod Serling era has
an average Tomato Meter score of 82%
and weighing it down is
it's only rotten season
during that time, season four at 57%.
All told "The Twilight Zone"
carries an average of 64%,
not bad for a concept that
has spanned half a century
and is still going strong.
But what happens when the
Zone glances into the mirror?
"Black Mirror" debuted overseas in 2011
and now has five seasons worth
of technological tomfoolery
brought to us by showrunners
Charlie Brooker and Annabel Jones.
"Black Mirror" has an
impressive overall average
of 83% on the Tomato Meter.
That's even more striking
when you consider
that the most recent
season is by far the lowest
with a still fresh 67%.
Season one's set the high mark at 98%,
and it's last three seasons
on Netflix average 79%.
For funsies that revolutionary
Bandersnatch project?
That was at 72%.
- Sounds awesome!
I see a trend.
Critics love these shows when they debut.
They're new, they're
different, they're creative,
and then it gets tougher and tougher
to match the original gut
punch as the shows carry on.
Is that how audiences feel too?
The average audience score
for "Black Mirror" is 81%,
and that once again,
handily defeats "The Twilight Zone's"
barely fresh average of 63%.
And oddly enough, it's
the Jordan Peele iteration
of "Twilight Zone" that's
weighing it down the most
at a rotten 39%.
Balancing that out is the
original Rod Serling run
which tops anything
else in "Twilight Zone"
or "Black Mirror" at 96%.
You see kids since the 1960s,
art has been all downhill.
We had The Zone, we had The Beatles,
who were heavily
influenced by The Monkees.
That should actually be an
episode of "Twilight Zone."
- You are obsolete, Mr. Wordsworth.
- Speaking of "Black Mirror",
that show also is experiencing
its audience score low point
with its most recent season.
Season five is being
a party pooper at 45%.
Maybe the quality has dipped
or maybe 2020 feels like one long episode
and we don't have the appetite.
These shows are many things,
but uplifting ain't
necessarily one of them.
May I suggest "Golden Girls"
or "Mama's Family" instead.
- Better late than.
(bell dinging)
Blanche!
- Pregnant!
- "The Twilight Zone"
gets major points in this
and every round for inspiring
tons of artistic endeavors,
including "Black Mirror",
but in this round,
it's not just about how you start,
it's how you finish and middle.
Because of that "Black Mirror"
squeaks by with the win
and takes a surprising
one nothing lead over "Twilight Zone."
(laughing)
- Jesus.
- Round two iconic moments.
And now is where "Black
Mirror" could shock the world.
In just five short seasons,
the show has managed
to carve out its own unique
spot in the cultural zeitgeist,
a word I'm 70% I just utilized accurately.
It's impressive enough
that "Black Mirror" managed
to separate itself from being labeled
just another "Twilight Zone" imitation.
All the iconic moments
it's already provided us,
that's just icing on the cake.
A cake that probably tastes
like licorice I'm betting.
The most obvious example would be
the moment that surprised the world
and dominated social
media in "Bandersnatch,"
an interactive movie revolution
that allowed the viewer
to make decisions and suffer consequences.
It was almost like a choose
your own adventure novel,
maybe a little too close.
It caused a lawsuit by Chooseco,
who owns those book rights,
and I dare anyone to prove
that they had heard of
Chooseco prior to right now?
But that episode also
snagged two primetime Emmys
and for once, gave
viewers a positive outlook
on a future where we get to interact
with our favorite TV
shows in a whole new way.
- It was ahead of its time
in as much as time exists.
- That's a considerable left turn
from the norm that is "Black Mirror."
Usually tech either falls into our hands
or is already in existence
and it's that obsession
that leads to our downfall.
Take the very first episode,
"The National Anthem."
I can't fully express the places
to which this episode
takes our imagination,
but needless to say it was
the perfect opening salvo
for the episodes to follow.
And if it's bleak you want,
how about that one with John Hamm
that got everyone talking and then crying
and then sighing and
then basically giving up.
What's it called?
The Christmas Episode?
Perfect.
We're all in a never ending
cycle trapped inside our minds.
♪ Fa la la la la la la la la ♪
(Christmas music)
When one thinks of specific moments
that unfolded in the show,
you could look at "Striking Vipers,"
one of the comparatively happier episodes.
Watching gamers fully
immersed inside a video game,
and then to see where that
action goes, it's groundbreaking.
Or when we realize just how far humans
are willing to go to avoid
embarrassment, and worse,
in "Shut Up and Dance."
Webcams and video games
weren't a thing yet
when Rod Serling kicked
off "The Twilight Zone"
and his imagination didn't need them.
His initial shepherding
of that show gave us
arguably as many iconic moments
as any other program in history.
I'm even talking to you
Monday Night Football,
bum, bum, bum, bum.
"Monsters Are Due on Maple
Street," "Mirror Image,"
and "Where Is Everybody"
are all landmark episodes in TV history
as is "Big Tall Wish,"
in large part due to the fact
that it was unfortunately rare
to have a black lead of a
show in the early 1960s.
As fan of the program myself,
I would instantly refer
someone to William Shatner's
slow unraveling "In
Terror at 20,000 feet."
There's a man on the wing.
- There's someone on the wing.
- Or a patient waking up
to a very different looking
doctor in "Eye of the Beholder."
"Twilight Zone" is at
its best in those moments
when the lead character
first starts to sense something is amiss.
Witness Anne Francis in "The After Hours,"
realizing that she is in fact a mannequin
or even at the very end
of "Time Enough at Last,"
as Burgess Meredith has one accident
that leads to a lifetime
of mental torture.
More recent incarnations
of "Twilight Zone,"
haven't born as much memorable fruit,
but there were a few moments.
In the 1980s, guest stars like
Bruce Willis would show up
and in his episode, "Shatterday,"
he was directed by horror
master, Wes Craven.
I'd also point you towards
the "Nightcrawlers" episode
and it's ultra violent conclusion
from "The Exorcist"
and "French Connection"
director, William Friedkin.
"Twilight Zone" has always
attracted A list talent,
so when Jordan Peele
agreed to take the reins
for a new generation, it was no surprise.
Already, his takes have
given us some clever updates
on "Twilight Zone" originals.
"The Comedian," and not just
because one's talking right now,
and the new and improved
"Terror at 30,000 Feet."
The "Replay" episode had a
darker "Groundhog Day" vibe
as does the Topher Grace
starring "Try, Try" episode.
the best one yet in my
not humble at all opinion
would be "Blurry Man,"
starring Zazie Beetz.
- You know what?
I think we can beat this.
- And for giggles, I do have to point out
that the 2002 reboot at least
had Forest Whitaker host
and there was an episode
where Katherine Heigl
went back in time to kill baby Hitler.
I'm pretty sure even the
stuffy suits at the TEC
in the 1994 classic "Time Cop"
would have approved that mission.
If Heigl wants to do it,
sure, send Katherine Heigl.
I like "27 Dresses."
- Mother!
- The shared DNA of these shows
is that beautifully twisted reveal
where we, the audience, are
rewarded for our suspicion
and are allowed in on the plot.
In "Black Mirror's", "San Junipero,"
we're hanging on before we realize,
oh, that, ah.
And in "Twilight Zone's" "Aliens,"
it's the very end when we
get conked on the head with,
wait, we're the?
These quotes weren't even
me playing coy with you
and not giving away spoilers.
That was genuinely word
for word my reaction
when the shows gave us the Full Monty.
Can I use that catchphrase
in this context?
"Black Mirror" is off to a hot start,
but it's going up against over 60 years
of "Twilight Zone" memorable moments.
And that's just me talking
about the Rod Serling era.
It was like 60 years worth of greatness.
"Twilight Zone" takes round two
and we're all deadlocked at one a piece.
- No logic, no reason, no explanation,
just a prolonged nightmare.
- Round three, cultural relevance.
We're all tied up but "The Twilight Zone"
starts round three with
dynamite field position.
If it's cultural relevance
the customer wants,
we don't have to go run to the back
and check the stock room.
We have decades upon decades of greatness
that has influenced pretty much
every other show ever in some fashion.
So why do I even bother
talking out round three?
Is it because I get paid by the word?
"Black Mirror" does actually
have a shot in this round
and not just because the show name itself
is constantly used to
describe anything weird
that happens in our lives.
Worldwide pandemic?
"Black Mirror".
iPhone FaceTime someone all by itself?
That's "Black Mirror".
The McFlurry machine is always broke
when I roll up to Mickey D's?
That is a recurring series
of "Black Mirror" episodes,
and I want it to stop,
but it also resonates with the culture
because it shows us
where humanity, society,
and technology is going.
If "The Twilight Zone" is an
alternate universe showcase
of basic carnal human instincts,
"Black Mirror" reveals to
us where those instincts
are gonna be taking us.
"Black Mirror" head
writer, Charlie Brooker,
has even pinned down current society
without writing an episode.
He was recently quoted as saying,
he doesn't want to write
season six right now
because the world is too bleak,
but it's also a better world
for having his show in it.
An article in "The
Independent" recently noted
that entertainment options
from "The Invisible Man"
to "I Am Mother to "Wounds"
and "Sorry to Bother You,"
have all been influenced by "Black Mirror"
and the show is frighteningly accurate
when it comes to
predicting how social media
can influence our world.
"The National Anthem"
and "Hated in the Nation"
are both harbingers of how apps
like Twitter can be used for good or evil.
And word is that China is developing
a networking system that is eerily similar
to one used in the "Nosedive" episode.
Heck, "Waldo" is an episode
where a cartoon character
gets elected president
and fascism is allowed to rule the day.
- No one takes you seriously.
That's why no one votes.
- And again, "Shut Up and Dance."
I can do nothing in that episode,
but I do enjoy the Aerosmith
song of the same name.
Brooker has claimed a number
of eclectic influences
on his own work with movies
like "Airplane" and "Evil Dead,"
as well as directors like Paul
Verhoeven making the list,
but one just needs to watch a few minutes
of any "Black Mirror" season to see
how heavily influenced it was
by the granddaddy of them all.
- Suspended in time
and space for a moment.
- Zone's cultural resonance
has never been stronger,
stemming from creator, Rod
Serling's own experiences
with PTSD following his
service in World War II.
Writing stories like the
ones found in his show
would prove to be a healing outlet
and through his work in the
realm of science fiction,
he was able to inject societal commentary
that normally wouldn't pass
the censors of his day.
Racism and struggles for equality
were a hallmark of the 1960s,
but rarely made it into TV shows.
Serling found that by
wrapping up his stories
under the label of fantasy
and including aliens
and the occasional monster,
he could get his message
across the airwaves,
right under the ad agencies
unsuspecting nostrils.
- The purpose, the point
of a dramatic show,
which is used as a vehicle
of social criticism,
is to involve an audience to show them
wherein their guilt lies
or at least indeed their association.
- If you wanna just
consider the horror genre,
watch an episode like "Mirror Image"
and see the evidence
that it inspired flicks
like "Psycho" and eventually "Us."
"Number 12 Looks Just
Like You" is a precursor
to the "Stepford Wives"
and "The Trade-Ins"
would help usher in the
concept of "Get Out."
The show had a huge impact on so many
of the artists we admire today,
from directors like Tim Burton
and M. Knight Shyamalan,
to writers like Stephen
King and Gene Roddenberry,
the series has been listed as
the seventh greatest show of all time
by "Rolling Stone" and placed fifth
on "TV Guide's" list of
the best dramas ever.
And in 1997, "TV Guide" listed
"To Serve Man" at number 11
and "It's Good Life" at number 31
in their best episodes
in TV history rankings.
And while the legacy
of "The Twilight Zone"
film is much darker,
as a wrongful death case was brought
on director John Landis
as a result of two actors
dying in an onset accident,
Landis was ultimately acquitted,
but that horrific day changed
movie set safety practices forevermore.
Jordan Peele and his love for Zone
are working to continue the legacy.
But regardless if he's successful or not,
one simply cannot overestimate
the breadth of "Twilight Zone's" impact.
Don't believe me?
Go watch any "Treehouse of
Horror" Simpsons episode.
Are you back?
Okay.
"Black Mirror" has a handle on technology
and where it's taking us,
but for now it's "Twilight Zone"
with the most cultural influence
of just about any show ever made.
It wins the round and goes up two to one.
- I mean, you shouldn't
say that such things
as nonsense and ridiculous.
- Well, that's the way it goes.
- And now it's time for the
wild card round, "The Creators."
Yes, in the wild card round,
we're going to pit the show's
creators against each other.
And if anyone could've seen that coming,
it's probably "The Twilight Zone"
or "Black Mirror" creators themselves.
Rod Serling with his knowing
grin and smoldering cigarette
versus Charlie Brooker, the wunderkind,
who if TV doesn't work out
can definitely fall back
as an Apple Store Genius.
Rod Serling gets huge points,
not just for fighting for
our country in World War II,
but using his experiences and trauma
as fuel for a creative outlet
that would be ahead of his time.
Years from now, we'll still marvel
at how much Serling got
right about humanity
and our most intimate biases.
But by then, we'll also be like,
"Hey, I'm addicted to this new app
"and that feels like a
"Black Mirror" episode."
In addition to being a
brilliant television writer,
Brooker is also an
accomplished cartoonist,
satirist and yes, even critic.
Is he certified on the tomato?
Maybe I'll I'll look into that.
Get back to you.
His comedy influences being from Britain
were naturally Monty Python,
and the way he can inject subtle humor
into even the bleakest "Black
Mirror" episode is impressive.
Even if the show ultimately
leaves us feeling
like our future is doomed,
the amount of variety with which
he can get us to that
conclusion is astounding.
In episodes like "Playtest,"
it's video games.
In "The History of You,"
it's a fancy contact lens.
And then "USS Callister,"
it's just unabashed love for "Star Trek."
With Rod Serling, a hopeful ending
was a little bit less of a pipe dream,
but more often than not,
we saw the light at the end of the tunnel
just before a massive
curve ball blew our minds.
"In to Serve Man," the aliens
are actually eating people.
"Nothing in the Dark" is another classic
and not just because a super
young Robert Redford was in it.
Did Rod Serling know back
then that Bob Redford
would go on to be a
secret member of Hydra?
- Am I really so bad?
- The leg up that Rod
Serling will always have
is his vintage appearances
in each episode,
later, paid homage by Forest
Whitaker and Jordan Peele.
Serling's handsome yet
singularly unique look
gave way to a voice
that could both comfort
and unsettle us in the same sentence.
Whatever was about to happen
or no matter the nutty
event we just witnessed,
Serling was always there to
offer appropriate context.
And when you look back
on those, it's also clear
he was reiterating to the audience
that the show we just watched
wasn't just about extra
terrestrials or the afterlife
or ventriloquist dummies.
It was about us.
- Any state, any entity,
any ideology that fails
to recognize the worth,
the dignity, the rights of
man, that state is obsolete.
A case to be filed under M for mankind.
- Brooker lets his tech wizardry
do the talking for him most of the time,
but it's no less effective.
One could conceivably form a spinoff show
just based on the practical
appliance of his imagination.
You're telling me you
wouldn't watch a YouTube show
about how to put your
dead partner into a robot.
Come on.
You've spent hours watching
grown adults unbox toys,
but you're telling me you
wouldn't check out soldiers
using the neuroimplant mass?
Get real y'all.
Brooker is a visionary
and I can't wait to see
where the rest of his
career takes him and us.
But the winner of the
wild card round is the guy
who came into everyone's living room
via TV set once a week in the 1960s.
America trusted Ed
Sullivan to tell the kids
what's going on in rock and roll
and it also trusted Rod
Serling to deliver messages
about ourselves wrapped
in a palatable shell,
of finely crafted horror sci-fi.
Rod Serling gets the point
and his baby goes up three to one.
- I think it's very possible
to perform a function
of providing adult meaningful,
exciting, challenging drama,
without dealing in
controversy necessarily.
- It was gonna be an uphill
climb for "Black Mirror" today,
which is not to say don't watch it.
In fact, I think it's one
of the best shows on TV
and it's shadow looms large
over the current version
of "The Twilight Zone,"
but for all the Zones that
have ever existed in history,
this isn't just a nostalgia win.
It's an earned victory that reminds us all
what the 1960s were really
about, societal change,
through politics, laws,
music, and storytelling.
For that, we all owe Rod
Serling a huge debt of gratitude
and I'm about to pay
him respect right now.
- Submitted for your approval,
a voting machine, the likes
of which will determine
the winner between two
television programs.
Although your narrator
appears to be in control,
the reality is he is
trapped in a dimension
from which he cannot escape,
awaiting the right comment
that may set him free,
or is he already free?
Fate is what we make of it,
both in your world and
here in the Twilight Zone.
(eerie music)